la candidate donc des vols semaine elle
a fait encore une fois beaucoup parlé ça
crée une énorme polémique sur twitter
puisqu'elle a posté sur instagram je
crois un tuto pour bien mettre en place
son ceinturon va regarder des images on
en parle juste après
[Musique]
gagnon oui voilà alors bon ça évidemment
choqué beaucoup de gens à ce que vous
êtes choqués pas choquer on a beaucoup
entendu on va laisser se reposer un peu
d'interviews les gens te remercie sur
twitter benjamin dvd m'a choqué pourquoi
parle par le tutoriel on est d'accord le
tuto ski à kia qui a fait polémique mais
n'ont pas choqué par le tuto mais
tellement choquée par les autres choses
tout les ainsi qu'à cependant
l'organisme
alors j'ai des trucs pareils je ne peux
pas les lire parce qu'ils sont
absolument mais d'abord ça donc voilà on
traite lyon traînent on passait pas
violent c'est dégueu l'innommable ce
qu'elle vit cette petite et ce depuis le
jour 1 de sympathie sa participation à à
the voice maintenant son tutoriel pour
pour installer son purement mais je suis
pas choqué du tout je vois pas pourquoi
ça choquerait qui que ce soit elle a 23
ans
on le rappelle quand toutes les petites
filles de 19 ans 20 ans font des tutos
make-up
personne n'est choqué donc je vois pas
pourquoi ça donne le point est ce que
souhaitait pas prendre un risque pour
elle
après ce qui s'est passé dans de voice
donc posté ce du nommé halo évidemment
et lui pose la question mais dans les
médias les gens aiment bien être
étiqueté ok elle fait de la musique et
les chanteuses et pourquoi ils
n'auraient pas le droit de faire des
tours d dit mais c'est quelque chose à
val gardena des internautes mais elle a
été critiquée à l'époque pour ses
théories du coup de complotiste elle
c'était maladroit elles sont excusés
aujourd'hui elle fait un tutoriel sur
les turbans health a ravivé de la
passion et surtout des réactions
racistes et ses sujets non parce que
c'était bien malin de faire ça mais
voilà exactement le vrai sujet c'est
quoi là je peux les états et les banques
tu m'as tu voi arrêtez moi je fais moi
je réfléchis à moi j'avais
[Rires]
mais si le sujet qu'un important
effectivement qu'elle fasse un tuto à
leur apprend malheureusement il n'y a
aucun problème en revanche faut pas
oublier non plus les tweets qu'elle
avait mis au des biens ci était quand
même assez immonde n'approuve pas les
oublier en revanche personne ne me fera
pas croire que cette fille n'a pas fait
ça pour faire le buzz oui c'est une
fille qui sait faire le buzz qui sait
faire parler d'elle elle a fait parler
d'elle une première fois par cette fuite
une deuxième fois évidemment quittant
démission assurant revenant avec l album
l cette règle savait très bien qu'en
faisant ça mais alors encore une fois ce
qu'ont dit les les trucs rassis monde
immonde mais évidemment qu'elle a
compris comment faire le buzz et je
trouve que pour cette jeune fille sort
c'est sûr justement sur ce genre de la
cgil gauche temps forts le body c'est
mal parce que c'est un site est
justement les gens à un peu à la haine
et à sortir des horreurs déco faire
attention à ça redonne à jamais moi je
trouve franchement tu veux je te dise la
vérité moi je lui dis merci parce que
c'est mon métier d'organiser des tutos
et tu le sais très bien très bien passé
le rapport alors écoute vais t'expliquer
il ya des centaines des milliers de
jeunes filles si on porte un turban qui
savent pas bien le maître et qu'une
salle aujourd'hui qui s'affirme et qui
revendique ce qu'elle fait et qui assume
totalement avec tout vos
toutes les insultes qui se prend dans la
gueule cette pauvre fille et ben oui
elle apprend à des jeunes à faire ce
qu'elle fait ce qu'elle aime à faire ce
qu'elle est ce cas là on vit bouche ou
magali magail et moi je suis d'accord
avec vous à 100 % ce problème c'est que
tout le monde mais qu'est ce qui pose
c'est est-ce que après tout ce qui s'est
passé mais voilà maintenant
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
moi j'aimerais pour clôturer qu'on
regarde la réponse de manège ce qu'elle
a fait une réponse en vidéo
regardez celle de jean moulin fut rendue
en fait je vous fais une vidéo gros coup
de gueule sur les réseaux sociaux comme
vous le savez je reçois beaucoup de
messages et je reçois aussi des messages
extrêmement violent je tiens à dire que
c'est inadmissible que je les cautionne
pas du tout mais je passe au dessus
parce que je me compte pas me rabaisser
à ce niveau là moi j'ai 23 ans mais je
pense à des autres filles peut-être
qu'ils sont plus jeunes que moi
eh ben ça peut détruire des vies après
je vous rassure
personnellement ça ne fait rien ça ne me
touche pas moi personnellement ça me
fait rire de voir des personnes si
frustré ça ne me fait absolument rien je
ne le prends pas pour moi
[Applaudissements]
magali réfléchi à tout petit peu quand
même t'imagines bien qu'avant cet
épisode va avancer plus tôt tu avais lu
aucun tweet ne par les an menm dit nous
comme on sait le turban donc et personne
n'a demandé ça c'est le fait si bien
quelque part il ya un peu de provoc
quand même voilà messina
[Musique]
ad je vous configurez à défaut de faire
de la provocation il
je pense que c'est évidemment une façon
de faire parler d'elle évidemment